doni vous en avez peut être aperçu cet
été les plages des sauveteurs en mer
rarement sur de grandes planches pour
secourir des baigneurs en difficulté
bien ce métier devenu une discipline
sportive le paddleboard c'est son nom
nous vient d'australie est la plus
grande course au monde a eu lieu hier
entre saint sébastien au pays basque
espagnol et capbreton dans les landes
éric pineault bernard von arb
on les appelle les watermen il s'apprête
à affronter la mer pendant 63 km sur la
plage de san sebastián encore enveloppé
par la nuit un seul équipage féminin ose
défier les autres quand on est un peu
dans la première de pâma l'équipe
masculine
donc voilà donc nous on va essayer de
dambach le plus possible et votre copine
donc on va bien se soutenir chacune à
faire quelque chose de bien ses trois
filles forment la dream team française
deux championnes d'europe en titre de
sauvetage côtier elle rivalise avec 27
équipages internationaux
les filles se relaient toutes les 20
minutes la course va duré plus de huit
heures notre objectif aujourd'hui c'est
de faire cinquième fait affaire monsieur
mais c'était vraiment super quoi à
l'arrière la cadence se ralentit et les
moins aguerris vont marine et jusqu'à 11
heures marcel l'alsacien se sont bien
loin de chez lui c'est en solitaire et
chez les hommes que se joue le record de
l'épreuve face à face un français
ludovic dulou et le champion du monde
l'australien de jamie mitchell 7 heures
24 minutes 20 secondes pour l'australien
le français suit à seulement 53 secondes
incroyable sur une telle distance je
peux même plus bouger je suis plus
capable de faire un pas j'ai des crampes
au niveau des cuisses et surtout là
derrière les tristes finalement le trio
féminin rentrer à capbreton après 8h38
dans l'eau catria l'équipage
objectif atteint